what's up everybody it's warren welcome
back to the cosmic wonder and wow today
we have received officially the biggest
spider-man no way home leak that has
ever been out there like seriously i've
heard of the actual plot to spider-man
no way home i have talked about the
actual plot to spider-man knowing home
this is bigger seriously this is a huge
leak and they are seriously doing
everything they can for this not to get
out which is why unfortunately i can't
show it but i can tell you exactly what
it is now we previously talked about
some leaked photos that sony was
copywriting and taking down from twitter
from youtube and recently from reddit
these photos were of tobey mcguire
spider-man andrew garfield spider-man on
top of some type of scaffolding and they
were in a huge huge blue room room
everything behind them was blue screen
and if you don't know this is so editing
can be done behind them now there was
some debate on whether or not these were
real or fake but they were pretty much
proven to be real i did hear from some
people who typically know what's going
on that they were real and then sony
started to copyright them proving they
are real but today is even bigger than
that as we got that photo essentially of
andrew garfield except it's a video
there is a video going around of that
exact scene of andrew garfield but he is
talking he is talking and looking in
different directions and some people are
saying that this is fake it's not and
seriously if this could be fake this
person whoever did this needs to be
working at marvel studios or nasa or
somewhere because it's the greatest
editing in the world if it is fake not
really sure what you could do at nasa
but you're clearly a genius if you
edited this to make it look the way it
did but seriously i've been sent this by
some people who send me legitimate leaks
and they're saying that it is indeed
real and again it's the same scene from
those photos that were taken down by
sony and be careful if you've posted
this to your twitter because it's on
twitter a lot right now so if you're
trying to see it just log onto twitter
but be careful about posting it or
reposting it to your account because
they clearly do not want this to get out
they don't want people to see this video
and i know a lot of people would
actually rather not see these things i
know a lot of people aren't like some of
us all the time they want as much
surprise as they can get i've already
had some people talking to me on twitter
saying that they wish they hadn't seen
it and it's hard to make out what he's
saying just because he's talking so fast
but it does look like he is saying the
word back so he possibly could be saying
how do we get back or how do we send
them back there are hands moving on the
left side of the screen which do look
like tobey maguire's spider-man hands so
what i'm assuming this conversation is
i'm assuming it's on top of a building
somewhere which is why they're on top of
the scaffolding and there's a huge blue
screen behind them i'm assuming they've
already fought or they're just now
coming together for the first time
talking about the villains and they're
trying to figure out the whole entire
thing tom hall and spider-man is
probably explaining to them well i kind
of broke the multiverse with doctor
strange that's how you got here and
that's how all of your villains got here
as well so this could be the
conversation on okay how do we get the
villains back and how do we get back
ourselves which is a conversation that
i'm sure everybody expected to happen
during the movie again this isn't really
telling us too much that we didn't know
about the film but it is pretty insane
to see something like this actually get
out but like i always say when movies
start to film or when they wrap filming
leaks get out unfortunately there are
just so many different people working on
the same project that it's really really
hard to contain these leaks and after
all we actually knew about the other two
spider-man joining tom hollands about a
year ago so of course worst kept secret
in hollywood sorry i can't show the
actual photo i know that's super
annoying but i hope you understand that
i could get in a lot of trouble if i
show it but seriously follow me on
twitter if you haven't because we have a
lot of cool conversations on there and
usually you can keep up to date with all
these things happening and know about
things before i actually do videos on
them my twitter handle is in the
description down below don't forget to
like the video and let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below and of course you can follow me on
instagram and tick tock as well and as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you